angas eats in the face of the refugee
crisis Hanley's Bedford storm theologian
Bishop of the evangelical lutheran
church in Bavaria and chairman of the
church conference of the evangelical
church in Germany calls on people to
stand together and assist the week and
downtrodden he is our interview guests
this week hello gasps hello hello hello
have you as a warm welcome to the
deutsche welle interview I'm Alexandra
phenomen Hobart foghorn mr. Bedford
storm what makes you so confident that
Germany can manage to integrate so many
refugees he Mele to physique I'll staff
found them I draw my confidence from
experience with people in Germany yeah
leave feel if we see that a great many
people probably more than 200,000 in the
Christian congregations alone are
working every day for the people who are
arriving here the uncommon people who
feel in their hearts that they have to
help people fleeing those horrible
situations in Syria that we see on
television first tell you not to talk
soon in Syrian TV that they have to find
refuge somewhere and I think it's so
impressive that so many people in this
real-life situation are acting on and
living out this basic impulse of
brotherly love of empathy which plays a
crucial role in the Christian faith
Jetson Clayton fitta had many people who
were providing volunteer at are saying
that's enough we're exhausted something
needs to change what's your answer to
this see ya didn't kick me golly I don't
answer that at all I listened and I hear
very different things keep this mint of
course there are people who are
exhausted after accomplishing a great
deal people who simply need to rest I
think but fortunately there are also
many people who are just setting off on
the path of helping people who can do
something done a high flame could what I
here on site at the refugee centers is
that people still have a great
willingness to help yep in politics
we're hearing harsh tones and they
obscure these helpers from sight
lesson in mind but when i visit the
congregation's i've been hearing
something very different people are
still willing to help and they can take
turns doing so in the head of it we
don't minimize this that's what really
kind reading at the same time it's also
clear that not every fugitive can come
to Germany that's why we have to seek
ways to make it possible for Refugees to
go elsewhere as well but Runkle if could
do that by simply closing the Borders or
setting an upper limit to how many
refugees will take dr. poon we also have
to make sure refugees are welcome in
other countries as well we have to work
on a number of points couldn't that was
one there are no simple solutions unsexy
but there are points that can contribute
I was keep sean anders punta atita 2 by
far the most important one is to remove
the causes of flight was that became fed
second most important is to provide the
camps around the conflict regions with
the means to feed the people they're
adequately and to ensure that their
children can finally go to school to
create the conditions that permit people
to stay there sample meaning a few days
ago you were one of the signers of an
appeal in which 10 organizations and
associations call for a Germany that is
open to the world and fulfills its
humanitarian duties I'm hurt why was it
important to you to sign this appeal
haunted session now this is from Las
guns / Saunders this alliance for an
open society is very special because it
consists of many organizations from the
middle of society CF which probably
represent more than 60 million Germans
the greater part of the population have
come together to send a clear signal
against populism against right-wing
radicalism in the increasing bitterness
of the debate its populace was getting
great radical is moes getting an
official forget about all these things
prevent us from seeing that these people
are in need and require help mentally
notes in these organizations reject
simple solutions and say if we all help
together all the people in these
organizations and I hope they'll be even
more if we all help together yeah then
we'll find ways of managing the
situation
which is difficult in many ways it's
also be very dignity in feelings if
there will be conflicts in integration
no we mustn't just give up about a
hundred see hints box [ __ ] we should
make use of this broad willingness to
help we should strengthen it and make it
sustainable Knutson dad and then maybe
in 20 years we'll look back on this
moment and say that we emerged from its
stronger than we went into it zambia
citric acid cycle house kickin ass very
9 becomes it come on Sean Christian but
you have understanding for people who
say that it's extremely difficult to
integrate so many people who are coming
to Germany because their attitudes
towards marriage and towards women
differ from what we have here one of
Cole Hamels fear not them he conflicted
definitely we can't pretend the
conflicts don't exist Deena gets awfully
we've experienced some things that show
how difficult it is but I think
precisely when we speak of possible
conflicts we need to keep bringing the
discussion to a sober objective level
because there's a lot of fear and
insecurity and play it might be that
simple Stan then fear is it feel so we
can't just refuse to talk about certain
things almost done I'd far we have to
call things by their right names say it
like it is and at the same time maintain
our objectivity by the bond and do them
out who in the appeal we mentioned you
also call on politicians to discuss
things objectively yourself have a
Social Democratic Party membership book
even if your membership is dormant what
do you think when SPD politicians like
social minister under the analysts say
public outlays should be cut for
refugees who don't abide by the values
of German society that 30 vetted a dog
what's your opinion of this I didn't pop
I politique English i'm not interested
in Party politics in the least when I
was in school I joined the SPD but that
plays no role at all today I'm a bishop
but even before I was at bishop party
politics was never at the center of my
interest people are work with commitment
in parties especially if they regard
themselves as Christians are obligated
to focus on the matter itself based on
our fundamental values
what do you think about statements like
that coming from various politicians of
course we have to talk about how to get
people to abide by the rules that are
valid here do you get it goes without
saying that the basic values of our
Constitution apply to everyone if your
allocated oh yeah we have to ask how can
we persuade people who come here and in
some ways have different ideas about
things like women's rights that we've
made great accomplishments here in
Germany that mustn't erode basically
whom shaft assists as we are here in
todd stance alike the commented for a
long time i'm in germany to equality for
women could not be taken for granted
hoyt they keep the stuff and there's
still a lot to do for it some i don't
think we can divide people into
categories these are people from outside
and these have lived here for a long
time all of society must implement the
values of the constitution and it's very
clear that we must do everything
possible so the people who come as
refugees adhere to them owned SS feliz
gladys man that's man Alice to Muslim it
mentioned the ads risking a calm sea
after we have to work out the best means
that's one best guidance but this isn't
just a matter of signatures or sanctions
it has to take root in people's hearts
and be a lasting part of integration and
justice in the Hudson calmed arising
consciousness at work is not hard to
help our end to this purpose what's most
important our discussions encounters an
experience with people mention about but
the Muslim congregations also have the
task and they're currently taking it on
I they're issuing their own brochures to
inform Muslim refugees that their own
tradition and the Quran don't place
women at a lower level all these are
crucial activities and I'm grateful that
they're coming from the Muslim
congregations themselves archive
estacado for me mostly machine your
minds and saves common cameras jananam
interview in an interview you said that
you are a very political person who uses
his office to take positions in
political debates wrote a manager
shouldn't a man of the church maintain
more reserved they've come come depends
type i already said party politics is
poison when it comes to the activities
of the church work
official skeet but certainly the basic
spiritual orientations that shape us
mean we can't remove ourselves from
politics central to Christianity is the
double commandment of love to love God
and to love our fellow man i discovered
unpinned but the two are inextricably
joined if I love my fellow man and his
suffering touches me and I can't ignore
politics I can't say I personally will
help another person but if there are
political reasons for his suffering i
can't say politics doesn't interest me
vegan that's why i always say a person
who is pious must also be political
party political not day-to-day politics
in the sense that representing the
church means i have better things to say
about current events but rather in the
sense that the plight of other people
has to touch us so that we want to
eliminate it and it's causes in that
sense one cannot withdraw from politics
come on heels the political kind fella
alsa the storms and ditched homes have
been theologians for generations and
your father was a Lutheran pastor as you
are did he have political discussions at
home your artist yes they always played
a role definitely discussion debate
discourse at the dinner table was part
of my life since I was a small child
side keep that our car and when we come
together as a family we still talk about
these questions they have a lot to do
with fundamental Christian convictions
to talk mythic history in Kundu what's
all going isn't internet worked
internationally lived in the United
States taught in South Africa your wife
is American how important is it for a
man of the church to know more than his
own country I month it's really an
integral part of our face because if we
truly believe in God if we believe in
Christ the one Lord Jesus Christ as the
New Testament puts it again and again
then we have to see the whole world as
our world I innovated scene I'm
traveling and visit partner churches
then I say to these people dear sisters
and brothers with this meeting that's
the root of this urge to go beyond our
own world I would like to come into
contact with these people from
completely different cultures
around us have them in contact and to
work for justice not only in our own
country once I'm worldwide made fight
this is something that comes from the
core of our religion camels of slums
house calmed social sister viola
Deutsche Welle interviews always end
with three unfinished statements
advisors of food so I'll ask you to
complete them as before as a bishop I
want to inspire people by say about how
bodying the values that I preach being a
role model in my expression of faith
through daily activities the refugee
crisis offers the opportunity that in
the sphere to unite in helping people
not to allow ourselves to be divided
what keeps us together is the basic
values that are crucial for the
Christian faith to that we work for the
benefit of those who are weaker than
ourselves Oh fer de shuang I'm Clayton
this will no longer be my Germany if the
Solidarity erodes people only think
about themselves and are no longer
affected by the fate of people in need
Tom shrieks I'll dimension denotes end
about what Thank You mr. Bedford
Stromberg thank you